[Musik]
er kommt von 213 essentielle dinge die
was für mich persönlich besonders
ansprechend waren dies sei zum einen die
feuerkraft der schutz und die
beweglichkeit
[Musik]
warum man doch mal mit donnern über die
freifläche drüber fort was man schon
dass sie doch einiges drinnen der
kampfbahn zeigt ja zu dem schwersten
waffensystem was man in österreich
besitzen die bestmögliche ausbildung und
durch schwerstmögliche und noch dazu die
zinsen im besten der welt dazu meine
herzliche gratulation aber nochmal danke
schön bei euch einen tag dabei sein zu
dürfen das war die erfüllung eines
kindheitstraums und ich muss halt machen